hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we will be looking at
another controversial
mlm arbonne now first i want to chat
about my sponsor squarespace so if
you're not familiar with squarespace
it's an all-in-one platform to run your
business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog
online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics
i am admittedly not very tech savvy
even though my whole job involves online
tech so
squarespace is great for folks like me
who really can't be bothered
tinkering with the back end and coding
and all that complicated stuff
we just want things to work so they have
some awesome
features that allow you to connect your
social media accounts collect donations
blog comment and gather analytics
literally it's the
one-stop shop of websites you can check
out squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain
also you can pause this screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
finally don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on a video
okay
so for the lucky few of you that have
not been approached by an arbonne sales
rep
and don't know what this business is
about arbonne is an international
multi-level marketing company founded in
the u.s in 1980
by pettermore since then it's grown into
a full-fledged operation with a product
line that ranges from
skin care and cosmetics to nutrition and
supplements
and when i say there is a range you guys
i am not kidding
there are literally so many products and
packages being sold
on this website that it would take me
weeks
to navigate the entire thing the
nutrition section
alone sells every trendy supplement
under the sun
from protein shakes detox teas energy
mixes body cleanses
and digestion capsules just to name
a few narrowing it down was a task
in itself but i thought since it is the
whole
new year new you season we would
naturally address some of the claims of
the arbonne
evolution for weight management package
so this package includes
two products full control and metabolism
support
so right off the bat i'm kind of annoyed
just at the names alone but before we
get into any of the specifics
i did want to talk about the industry
funded study that this whole line
is allegedly backed up by so this was a
16-week clinical study
in which participants supplemented with
both weight management products
plus the arbonne protein shake and also
we're on a calorie restricted diet
with moderate exercise now although
arbonne likes to
brag about the positive weight loss
results which side note
we're modest at best the truth is the
impact
of these supplements cannot be teased
apart from the calorie restricted diet
and exercise i don't have evidence of
the relative impact of those powders and
pills but i do have a critical mind
with a serious spidey sense my spider
senses are starting to tingle
for wellness culture bs and honeys
it is going off moving on let's talk
about the kiwi watermelon
full control supplement which while
super cringy
is kind of a brilliantly marketed name
people love the idea of control
control over your diet control of your
body control over your health but in
real life
even the most dedicated regimented
people do not have
full control over how their bodies look
perform or respond to anything
any diet or in this case product that's
guaranteeing you
full control over anything is using
exploitive
marketing tactics to get you to buy more
anyway
according to the arbonne website the key
ingredient that gives the supplement its
controlling characteristic is a
substance called glucomannan
now glucomannan is a sugar made from the
root of the konjac
plant usually used as a thickener or
gelling agent
in the context of our body it's actually
used as a high fiber
water soluble laxative used for
relieving constipation and also for
making us feel more
full but aside from the general role of
fiber and weight management which
by the way is true for any source of
food derived fiber
not just supplements like these one
study did suggest that
glucomannan specifically did not promote
weight loss
change in body composition or even
affect one's hunger and fullness cues
in addition there is research to suggest
that glucomannan can cause
negative gi symptoms like gas abdominal
pain
gastrointestinal obstruction as well as
possibly modifying the extent to which
we absorb
other medications so yeah
if you want to be in control of your
bathroom behaviors
you might want to flush that supplement
down the lid
the next claim of full control is that
it supports
blood sugar and cholesterol levels
already within
a normal range to be honest
this sentence touts a lot of fancy words
designed to impress health-conscious
consumers
while also playing it safe by fda
marketing claim
regulations when i hear it though i hear
something like healthy food
keeps you healthy if you're already
eating a healthy diet
obviously anyways studies do suggest
that glucomannan fiber
does have positive effects on lowering
both cholesterol
and blood pressure which is obviously
great however
it's also important to point out that
similar to the whole fullness increasing
powers of this product this is actually
just
another general benefit of getting more
soluble fiber in your diet
it doesn't have to be from glucomannan
in this arbonne
branded supplement so you can find
soluble fiber in foods like
oats beans apples and pears now the last
claim of this product is that the
magnesium in it contributes to energy
yielding metabolism from carbohydrates
fats and proteins while supporting
healthy bones
again i'm a trained professional in
nutrition and dietetics and
even i am having a hard time decoding
their
nutritionist you know sometimes brands
take a bunch of buzzy words that people
recognize like
energy metabolism and carbohydrates and
then they throw them together in a
sentence that
doesn't mean a whole lot and they just
hope that people don't ask questions
but this to me is basically just
describing
magnesium's role in energy production in
the body
and helping to mobilize energy from the
food that we eat it's actually just
a part of normal healthy metabolism
not something that will magically make
you lose weight
now in terms of the latter half of that
statement magnesium itself is an
essential mineral that is definitely
crucial for a number of bodily processes
including bone formation however
although the research
is promising the exact relationship
between magnesium intake
and bone mineral density is still not
fully
clear while supplementing with magnesium
can serve as a preventative measure
against bone degradation
and osteoporosis for those who have
proven magnesium
deficiencies there really is no proof
yet
that the general population needs to
supplement with magnesium for our bones
in fact too much magnesium can actually
reportedly have
adverse effects on bone health lastly
let's talk about price
while arbonne's product sells for 68 per
tub which is about
10.8 ounces of product other fiber
supplements that are equally as
effective
sell for as little as 11.59
for basically the same amount of product
now i understand splurging every now and
again especially when it comes to
products for our health but a nearly 60
difference is definitely noteworthy
listen
i am all for taking fiber supplements if
you're having a hard time getting in
your 25 to 38 grams per day
fiber has so many important roles in
heart health
digestion weight management and more but
it's
not a weight loss panacea and there's
not much magical or
special about this particular brand so
yeah you can probably take a pass
next in their weight management line we
have the metabolism support capsules
because again
everyone and their mother is obsessed
with fixing their metabolism
now the star ingredient in this product
is called spatol which
is a green coffee bean extract rumored
for its alleged weight loss benefits
but let's see what the evidence suggests
so
one meta-analysis concluded that
although results from some of the small
trials
were promising more research is still
needed to assess the usefulness of green
coffee bean extract
as a weight loss tool it's important to
note however
that most of the research that supports
using svetol
for weight loss were done either in
vitro
or in animals and although these studies
still do hold some value
they're largely just a jumping off point
for further exploration
not something that you want to write
home to your mom about also in one of
the three human studies we saw
two participants had to drop out due to
the adverse health effects that they
were experiencing
such as headaches and urinary tract
infections
also only a few of the studies published
were in compliance with the us food and
drug administration guidelines which
means there were significant
limitations to the research in these
studies so
conclusion we're just not quite ready to
call this in
as a magical skinny substance
but wait oh just wait folks these bad
boys
also contain some targeted botanicals to
support metabolism
but to save you all some time i will
just remind you that
there is no magical ingredients that
have any meaningful impact
on the speed of your metabolism friends
your metabolic rate is
largely determined by your body
composition
your caloric intake your age and your
genetics your
muscle to fat ratio the amount of
physical activity you do
and hormone function there is no mix of
ingredients chemicals
enzymes or in this case botanicals that
will magically speed it up i should also
note that i really hate the lack of
transparency here on exactly
what's even in this blend herbs may be
natural but they're not benign
and not disclosing how much of the herbs
are in each pill
makes it really difficult for people
like me to call it as bs
but also makes it difficult for
consumers like you to know what you are
getting
some herbs may interfere with
medications or not be safe for
particular people
or different stages of life so i would
avoid
any product where you don't know exactly
how much of what ingredient is inside as
for the ingredients themselves
let's look at each of them and their
connection to metabolism
so first although human studies
regarding green tea and metabolism
are limited the catechins in green tea
do
show some promising results for having
beneficial effects
on weight management glucose control and
cardiovascular risk factors
however most studies suggest that you
would need to consume as many as
nine cups of green tea per day to see an
impact which
may or may not be realistic for most
people next
while the research on capsaicin or chili
peppers in humans is limited
one small study in the journal of
nutritional science and vitaminology
found that
eating a little over a gram of red chili
pepper
could help contract the metabolism
slowing effect
of a 20 reduction in consumed calories
others have echoed this by demonstrating
small impacts on post meal energy
expenditure
fat burning and carbohydrate oxidation
all that said
large good quality research is still
very limited
and what impacts we do see are
relatively small
so if you like heat go for it add all
the chili that you want but i wouldn't
ruin your eating experience
for the sake of a potentially very small
boost in metabolism third let's talk
about cocoa
so the flavonols in cocoa do appear to
reduce some of the risk factors
associated with the development
of metabolic syndrome such as reducing
ldl cholesterol
liver inflammation and triglyceride
buildup in the liver
as for ginger a meta-analysis did find
that
regular ginger consumption was
associated with various weight loss
parameters such as body weight
heart rate increased hdl cholesterol and
decreased ldl cholesterol but i think
it's worth noting that
all of this data that i'm citing is
largely
correlational so it doesn't prove
causation in other words
we don't know if people who consume a
lot of cocoa or ginger are just kind of
healthier people
or if maybe there's something magical
about the compounds themselves
anyway the next claim similar to the
previous one
about the full control states that this
supplement helps to metabolize carb
proteins and fats and also helps to
maintain healthy blood pressure levels
and support cardiovascular health that's
a lot to unpack
just in one sentence but first similar
to the metabolism support claims that we
just
talked about let me once again assure
you that
your body is a highly complex and finely
tuned
network that is extremely efficient at
metabolizing the food that we eat
there's even an entire organ system in
your body
dedicated to doing just that i'm looking
at you digestive system but it's also
important to note that these capsules
also contain a flavonol called quercetin
which is an antioxidant found in foods
like apples berries and onions
studies have found an association
between quercetin and a reduced risk of
coronary heart disease
stroke and blood pressure again
association
not causation not to mention we also
don't know
if it's more effective to consume these
compounds from
actual foods versus expensive powders
but anyways
more on that in a minute the last claim
about these capsules is regarding its
green tea extract which contains
caffeine that supposedly supports
thermogenesis now for those of you who
may not know thermogenesis is the
process of heat production in living
beings
and heat production is a byproduct of
calorie burning
therefore thermogenesis has become a
super trendy buzzword
in wellness culture over the past few
years but it's really just
another more scientific way of talking
about metabolism
so again arbonne's pr team was just
filling up their wellness diet bingo
cardigan
with some more flashy words now while
there is evidence to support the idea
that thermogenesis can help amplify
weight loss efforts the effects
don't seem to be overly significant most
studies assessing the effects of
thermogenesis
are also done in conjunction with a
calorie restricted diet so again
it's hard to say how much of any of
these thermogenesis boosters
play a role in weight loss now to the
cherry on top is
arbonne's suggestion that these two
supplements will not
work best unless you spend money on both
of them
and use them at the exact same time
which takes us up to about 130
a month on unnecessary supplementation
uh congratulations
i am all for supplements used
strategically and
there's nothing inherently bad about
these supplements
but there's also nothing magical about
their use either
any weight loss benefits derived from
the individual ingredients
in vitro that is in a petri dish
in a lab or a very small controlled
study
would probably be so minute in real life
without that caloric restriction or
exercise and any additional nutrient
benefits that you might get from a
supplement like this
could easily be achieved much more
efficiently
and economically from whole foods and if
arbonne's bogus claims in overpriced
nutrients isn't enough to turn me off
its sketchy business model
definitely is it's not a pyramid scheme
it is a
it's not even a scheme per se it's
so mlms are basically known for their
marketing strategy where they use
non-salaried sales representatives to
distribute and sell their products
multi-level marketing is a strategy used
to encourage
existing sales representatives to
recruit new distributors
who are paid a percentage of their
recruit sales
or just get other salespeople in general
however mlms like arbonne have been
under fire in the media
for its alleged pyramid scheme like
tactic arbonne uses what they call
independent consultants to sell products
you know the people who message you on
facebook that call you babe
and tell you that they've got a business
opportunity for you
yeah those poor souls are harassing you
for money
because they had to pay a 59
registration fee
to become a consultant yes they had to
pay arbonne
to get the job honestly the internet is
filled with so many war stories of
people
minding their own business on instagram
only to get spammed with some
pitch to become a boss babe you
probably have your own anyway according
to a few online blogs and articles
none of which i can substantiate so
please do take this with a grain of salt
but apparently every consultant must
spend 150
each month on arbonne products every
month
in order to earn their commission and if
you don't spend the necessary amount of
money on arbonne products each month
you won't receive commission on your
sales
and will therefore be working for free
please correct that
in the comments if i am wrong but that
is what i was reading online
so who would do that i guess they're
consultants
by signing other people up they reduce
their own
costs now mlms also manage to carefully
word their terms and conditions
in a way that avoids any incriminating
legal issues
if you don't want to become a consultant
you can opt to become
a preferred client where if you pay a 35
registration fee you can get 40 off all
product
however this is just one example of the
type of kind of
sign up and receive discount arbonne
offers to its users
from what i can understand and i'm not a
lawyer kaboom you've been lawyered
all of these tactics are legal and legit
but are they morally right
well to be honest there are so many
different plans
roles random discounts loopholes and
fees
spread throughout the site navigating
this website and everything they were
trying to offer
was a legitimate maze so please if you
have your own experiences with arbonne
i would love to hear them in the
comments none of this is from my own
experience
but these were just some of the claims i
was reading about online
now to finish off this review of arbonne
let's talk about its safety and testing
there are a ton of buzzwords all over
the website like pure
safe and certified arbonne clean how
reassuring
right well they also have something they
call a not
allowed list which is composed of the
top 10 ingredients
they do not allow in their products
including all the usual suspects
formaldehyde animal products parabens
bha
soy canola oil trans fats carrageenan
etc
now although they have done their due
diligence in terms of making sure the
products are safe for consumption
like most supplements they're not
regulated by the fda
arbonne's website does suggest that
they've conducted independent third
party testing but i wasn't able to find
any additional details about that so
again when you're choosing a supplement
you can always check out its status on
websites like labdor.com
or nsf.org well folks that is all for
today
thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below if there's any other
mlms that you want me to review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye